LAURENCE MORONEY: If
you've watched any Ruby
videos on YouTube,
you've probably
seen Aja Hammerly at work.
Today, she's joining me to geek
out over various hot beverages
or just find somewhere
that serves tea.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Aja, every time
I go onto YouTube
and I'm looking for
something Ruby, you're there.
How much Ruby stuff do you do?
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, I did a lot
before I started a Google.
It was my community.
I've been doing
Rails Dev since 2007.
And I started speaking.
Because there was
an event in Seattle.
And they're like,
hey, this thing
you've been doing in
our weekly meetup,
are you willing to
talk about it on stage?
And I'm like, I'm
not good enough.
And they're like, sure you are.
Just come do it.
And I realized I
really like speaking.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You're
really good at it.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thank you.
And I love the Ruby community.
I love the language.
I love the fact
that it's supposed
to make programmers happy.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Does it?
AJA HAMMERLY: It makes me happy.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Well that's good.
That's a good start, right?
AJA HAMMERLY: Some
of the folks I
know who do Python think
it makes them angry.
But different strokes
for different folks.
But actually at
Google, I've been doing
a lot of stuff that isn't Ruby.
I've been focusing
on some DevOp stuff.
And now, I'm doing
a lot of stuff
around language communities.
Because one of the things I
learned from the Ruby community
is that every community,
every language community,
has different values, different
things that they think
are important.
What's important
to a Java developer
is not going to be what's
important to a Rubyist,
important to a Node developer.
And we're trying to figure
out how we can make our cloud
products and our
cloud libraries feel
good to all of these
different communities
and meet these communities
where they're at.
And it's fun, it's challenging.
But we need people who actually
know our communities well
to be able to do that.
So the fact that I'm still
in the Ruby community
is important.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So how
do you go about doing that,
like working with
different communities?
AJA HAMMERLY: So in
the Ruby community,
one of the things
that's really important
is that we need to
be newbie friendly.
There's a lot of folks who
learned Ruby at code bootcamps.
And they haven't been
programming for very long.
So we need to make sure that
our documentation is top notch,
that our APIs makes sense.
In the Node community,
we need to make sure
that we install via the tools
that they know how to use
and that we meet them
where they're at.
So we need to have good
support for WebSockets.
We need to have good
support for concurrency.
So there's a lot of cool stuff
without going on in Node.
Python community,
we need to make sure
that we have libraries for the
scientific computing folks,
in addition to all the web
stuff that happens in Python.
Python is well-adopted in
lots of different places.
And so it's just making
sure that we bring folks
into Google, who know
those communities, who
are part of those communities.
Externally, it seems
like all I do is Ruby.
Internally, I do so much more.
But I love my Ruby community.
You will drag my Ruby
community away from me
with me kicking and screaming.
They are my people.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, we
don't want to do that.
AJA HAMMERLY: They're my people.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So now, do you still
go to a lot of Ruby
events and talk at them?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, I try to
get to four or five a year
at least.
I try to make sure I make it
to the big ones, a RailsConf
in the US and
RubyConf in the US.
I went to RubyKaigi in
Japan, which is the big Ruby
conference in Japan last year.
And it was amazing
and intimidating,
being in the place
where the language was
created with a lot of the
core contributors on stage.
And I'm just like,
I don't belong here.
And they're thinking
about where Ruby's
going to be in five years.
And I'm just like,
this is not something
that I get to think
about very often.
It's so cool.
And I like going to the events.
Since I've been part of the
community since 2007ish,
I like the fact that,
when I go to the events,
I get to do some mentoring.
At RailsConf, I got
to have a person who
was new to the community
was my mentee for the week.
And I suggested talks
to her and told her,
based on her
interests, what stuff
I thought would be relevant.
And she asked me questions.
And it was great.
And I love giving back.
Because there was so many
people who did that for me
when I joined the community.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And it's always
good to be able to
get back in that way.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
now, you're in Google.
You're working as a
Cloud Developer Advocate.
What does Ruby
look like in cloud?
AJA HAMMERLY: So when I
started, we had some stuff.
But I've been with Google
now for 2 and 1/2 years.
And cloud has just exploded,
especially Google Cloud
has just exploded in that time.
We now have App Engine Support.
So you can run an
App Engine with Rails
and Sinatra, our two
big web frameworks.
And it mostly just
works out of the box,
which I'm really happy about.
Because that's what
the community wants.
We have libraries for
cloud machine learning.
Some of those are in beta.
We've got libraries for
cloud logging, [? starring ?]
Stackdriver Logging.
And that's GA now at this point.
And the cool thing is that I'm
seeing that I go to events.
And people are like,
yeah, I saw your talk
a year ago or two years ago.
And we tried it out.
And we really like it.
And I'm like, awesome,
can you tell me
what you don't like so
we can fix that next?
Because my big thing
is I want to make sure
that my community is
delighted, and happy,
and they're being
well-served by Google Cloud
and by cloud in general.
Because I've been the one
who's had to rack the servers.
I have the bloody knuckle.
I had the bloody
knuckles to show for it.
I don't ever want anyone
to have to do that again,
unless it is the right
choice for their company.
I don't want it to be buy
your servers off eBay,
and rack them up in some cheap
[INAUDIBLE] as the default.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hands
up if you've done that.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, it
was unfun when I did it.
It was unfun carrying a pager.
And I'm really glad that,
for a lot of these folks who
are working at startups, they're
able to have someone else,
have Google do their SRE, have
someone else do their SRE,
so that they can focus
on building cool stuff
and not focus on
the how do I make
sure it stays running parts.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So your journey,
you were very much in
the Ruby community.
And then, you joined Google.
And what was the difference?
How does it feel to be
part of such a big company,
but still working on
something like Ruby?
What is it like to just join
Google and do this stuff?
AJA HAMMERLY: So before Google,
I had basically every job
pretty much that you can
have in web development.
I was a tester.
I was a position that
seems to only exist
in Washington state, a software
development engineer in tests.
LAURENCE MORONEY: In one
particular company, too.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, I was
a developer at a startup.
I was a tester at a startup.
I was a release
manager at a startup.
I carried the pager there, too,
because, you know, started.
I worked in consulting for
a while doing a combination
of DevOps and development.
And a friend of mine worked
on the cloud team, Julia.
And she's like,
hey, we're hiring.
And I'm like, I don't
think I'm qualified.
She goes, throw a resume
in, you're qualified.
And I'm like, I don't think so.
And she convinced me.
And I'm like, well,
OK, if I interview,
will I get free lunch?
She goes, yeah.
So I'm like, OK, I will
do it for the free lunch.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I
met you at that lunch.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, you did.
And it was delicious.
And it ended up working out.
And I was super freaked out.
And I'm like, well, I can go
to this giant company, work
on a small team,
which my preference is
small team at big company.
Because you get the camaraderie,
and the teamwork, and the
we're all in it together
of a small company.
But you have all the
benefits of a big company.
And I got to still
say my message.
I got to still to meet
with my Ruby community.
I didn't have to give
up my Ruby community
for some of the languages that
Google is more well known for.
And I also had to
do other cool stuff.
And I get to be
surrounded by all
of these really smart people.
And I've worked at
a lot of places.
But this is the place
where I feel most at home.
I'm surrounded by all
of these giant dorks,
giant nerds, people with all
these really cool habits.
I was talking to one
of my coworkers--
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
the nicest thing anybody
ever called me, thank you.
AJA HAMMERLY: I was talking to
one of my coworkers on Friday.
He goes, its just one of those
Google things that you're like,
wait, you write a lot of
code, and you're really
well known in this community?
Oh, and you're a concert level
concerto violinist on the side?
Of course you are,
because it's Google.
And so having all
these people who
are just super into awesome
stuff is so much fun.
And everyone just kind of
accepts me for who I am.
And I love it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's one of
the most beautiful things we're
doing here is being
accepted for who you are.
For me, when I first joined,
it was the imposter syndrome,
like do I really fit here?
I mean, when's the other
shoe going to drop?
But then, once you
realize and you fit in
that everybody has their own
quirks, everybody's different.
And that's part of what
really brings people together.
And I think it helps us to
then work with developers.
Because then, we understand
other people's differences,
too.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, at the
end of the day, most of my job
is translating Googler into
developer and developer
back into Googler.
Because the bottom
line is that this
is a really big company, with
some really unique problems,
and some really neat
ways that Google
has chosen to solve those
problems, many of which
we've written papers about.
But the vast majority
of the communities
that I reach, small
startups, medium
sized companies, companies that
have five different languages
inhouse, because that seems
to be more and more the case.
They don't have the
problems we have.
They have different problems.
They have different priorities.
And making sure that,
in cloud, we're me
we're reaching them with a
message that makes sense,
we're helping them out, we're
helping them build cool stuff.
At the end of the day,
when people are like,
what does a developer
advocate do?
And I'm like, I help people
build cool stuff, I hope.
It's been fun and hard.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So one of the things
that you mentioned earlier
that stuck in my mind
was, when you were
talking about communities,
one of the things
communities are
good at is,
particularly in Ruby,
that people have learned
Ruby in a bootcamp.
And to get that
support for people
who are beginning their
journey as a developer,
not just in Ruby but, of
course, in other languages, what
do you offer from your
team on cloud for,
if I'm a new
developer and I want
to get started in building
awesome cloud apps with Ruby?
How would I get going?
AJA HAMMERLY: So if you're
going to build awesome cloud
apps with Ruby,
you're probably going
to be using Rails, or Sinatra,
or something else that's
based on our underlying web
support, which is called Rack.
And the best thing you can
do is go try out App Engine.
And the place you go for that
is Cloud.Google.com/Ruby.
And if you're in
another language,
Cloud.Google.com/
your language here.
It will get you to the
Getting Started stuff.
In Ruby specifically, one
of the best things we offer
is App Engine for Rubyists.
It lets you spin up a server.
It will autoscale,
if you turn that on.
And really, all
you need to do is
create an account on our website
and go GCloud App Deploy.
And the little script says, it
looks like you're running Ruby.
And that is the
last thing it says.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Is there a
little Clippy that says that?
AJA HAMMERLY: It's
the last thing it
says that sounds like Clippy.
And then, you say, yes.
And all the defaults work
with the standard ways
that people run Rails apps.
You can just say
yes at that point.
And your thing will be running
in the cloud within 10 minutes.
It's fantastic and amazing.
And I've been using it for
some of the nonprofit work
I do as side projects.
Because it's so much
easier than having
to provision a compute
instance and make sure
that I have the latest versions
of all this stuff installed.
And we tested our App Engine
with the top 1,000 libraries,
Gems, that people run with Ruby.
And all of them install cleanly.
So if you're using
it, it probably
just works out of the box.
And that is lovely.
Because if you want
an attachment thing
and you need
ImageMagick, you don't
want to have to think
about which C libraries
you want for ImageMagick,
especially if you're new
and you're not even sure
what C library extensions,
and apt-get, and all that are.
You just want it to work.
Because you want to get about
building your cool thing.
AJA HAMMERLY: Because that's
always the thing that,
when you want to start learning
particularly a new language,
you really don't want to deal
with all the dependencies.
And you don't want to deal
with like the infrastructure
and that kind of things.
It's like, I just want to
write, print "Hello world,"
and get it to work in the cloud.
And so all of that is done, if
you're doing it on App Engine.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, if you're
doing it on App Engine,
that is all done.
I the Node.js.
Because I'm trying to get
back up to speed on Node.js.
I did Node.js before
Google professionally,
and then haven't touched
it for two years.
And that community has
gone so far, so fast.
I'm trying to get back up
to speed on Node right now.
And I don't want
to have to remember
how to provision a node server.
Eventually, I will remember.
But right now, I just want to
verify that I still know Node.
I'm doing one of my
projects on App Engine, too,
just to make sure that I
still remember how to do it.
And I'm like, yeah,
I want to remember
how to make cool stuff.
I don't want to remember the
provisioning bit right now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And people worry
about things like App
Engine, that they're
going to be locked in.
And the nice thing
about the way we've
done with App Engine
Flexible for Ruby and Node
is that there's a
Docker Container.
The Docker File is
available on GitHub.
So you know exactly
what we're installing
and exactly how
we're running it.
And so if you decide that
you're done with App Engine
and you want to move to
something else, it's there.
You can just pick it up
and move it to Compute.
You can pick it up and
move it to Kubernetes.
And I like that.
Because it gives people
a lot of flexibility,
which is the other thing that
my community really wants.
So they want to be
able to move, if that
is the right choice for them.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So you've clearly
worn a lot of hats
in your career.
And you've worked very closely
with a lot of communities.
If somebody is just getting
out and getting started now,
what advice would you give them?
AJA HAMMERLY: Play.
One of the biggest things that
made my career go well and gave
me a lot of opportunities
was I started
going to the
Seattle Ruby Brigade
meetup on a weekly basis.
We have one of the
core Rails contributors
and a lot of people
in Seattle who've
written libraries
that are core to Ruby.
That meetup is the longest
lived Ruby meetup in the world.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
Even outside of Japan,
where it was invented?
AJA HAMMERLY: Even
outside of Japan.
I think we're at 15 years now,
something crazy like that.
And every week, I showed up.
And I just wrote some code.
Most of it was throw away.
In fact, the vast
majority of it was awful.
And sometimes, I
would be like, here's
this Python script I found.
Let me try to port it to Ruby.
Or I wonder if I can use a web
scraper to do this cool thing
that I've been thinking about.
And I would get
feedback from some
of the folks in the community.
I'd see someone
working on something.
I'd be like, what's that?
Can I try that?
And they'd point me in
the right direction.
And writing that code,
getting that feedback,
and just playing,
and having fun,
and remembering that this is
why we do this kept me going.
And that's how my first
speaking opportunity showed up.
And that's how some of the
open source stuff I have done
happened.
And I get to meet a
lot of cool folks.
And it made it easier to
get this job in developer
relations.
Because I'm relating
with developers.
And I still do
almost every Tuesday.
And we occasionally have talks.
I spoke at every meeting for the
first year we had talks again.
And I have spoke last month.
And it was the first
time in a year.
And I was very happy that
I hadn't spoke every month.
But it's fun.
Like last week, I was there
writing a Battleship program.
Because for some
reason, I've decided
I'm going to write
Battleship this month.
LAURENCE MORONEY: E6,
Miss, that Battleship?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yes,
exactly that Battleship.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK,
you sunk my Carrier.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yes, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, interesting.
AJA HAMMERLY: And
I'm going to do it
as a multi-language project.
I'm going to write clients in
a bunch of different languages.
And it's fun.
And if it's not fun,
you're not going to do it.
And if you're not doing it,
you're not going to get better.
So play, have fun, that's
the big piece of advice
I have for folks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah,
I think the biggest skill
you can have is the ability
to spend time and the desire
to spend time on these things.
So cool.
Well, thank you so much, Aja.
This has been a blast.
I've had a lot of fun.
And so thank you so much.
And to learn more about
what Aja is working
on, Cloud.Google.com/Ruby,
right?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yes,
that's correct.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Cloud.Google.com/Ruby
or Cloud.Google.com/ insert
your language of choice,
so that you can get started with
your language and your language
of choice and the cloud.
And I hope to see the
kind of cool stuff
that you're going to build.
So thanks again, Aja.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]